we get the return of Dancing with the
Stars now the cats too will be
officially announced tomorrow but there
was already controversy surrounding some
of the rumored contestants so are the
stars of this season really amateurs so
how is this fair starting in 2007
Heather Moors was literally queen bee's
backup dancer for two years we're
talking about the young people and then
the now 30 year old mother of two was
hired on Glee after she taught the
single ladies choreography to the rest
of the cast with moves like that it's no
coincidence
Heather's character was named to Britney
Spears and now she's going to be an
average contestant on Dancing with the
Stars I'm a dancer I've been dancing
since I was two and a half probably I
started taking dance classes and it
doesn't end there a source tells us that
her husband cared for now with fan
favorite new dad max mere husky but
there are other rumored contestants who
may have an unfair advantage as well we
have confirmed ice skating star Nancy
Kerrigan Olympic gold medal gymnast
Simone biles
and mr. t who could survive based on
personality alone and now we're hearing
fifth Harmony's normani four-day is on
the show
you could call the 20 year old singer /
dancer this year's Pussycat Doll
remember 2010 - for Scherzinger won the
bear ball although we gotta say this
girl group demo appears to be a little
more fist pumping arriving to the beat
and cha-cha and rumba no doubt rumored
contestant Charo also used to be a
professional dancer so what are
Dancing's rules when picking the cast
well we spoke to pro Witney Carson who
danced the Carlton with 2014 winner
Alfonso Ribeiro she explained as long as
you don't know ballroom you're accepted
on the show
even if you've danced your whole life
they're like come on and you're like
that's fair
[Music]
you